très soldat je saute en parachute de
n'importe quel avion en vol
je me suis porté volontaire
bien les aléas mon choix
où est le reste de votre unité non où est
le reste de la vôtre DIPA martelly minimoho
jacilla visa pierres il mondo films quand
il est venu le voir marché d'antiquités les gens la
console était  accidentellement enterrée au-dessus,
elle a dit qu'elle pouvait nous aider, elle veut d'abord notre
aide avec quelle aide avec ce qu'elle
veut que nous trois un groupe de ses
amis de la résistance, elle pourrait
conspirer avec les nazis, nous conduisant
directement dans un piège, comment savons-nous que
c'est '  Pour une embuscade,
nous devrions faire cela rapidement ou nous perdons l'
objectif. J'ai un soldat aéroporté
un parachutiste.
Je me suis porté volontaire pour le faire en connaissant bien
les dangers de mon choix.
je te fais